[Music]
this is the world's most violent tribe
known as the sentinelese
last year in 2018 an american missionary
was murdered when he tried to evangelize
them
indian officials won't even dare to
retrieve his body
nearly everyone who has ever tried to
contact them has been met
with spears and with arrows and some
unfortunately never left the island
alive
for centuries they've remained virtually
isolated on this remote island
in the middle of the indian ocean almost
nobody
dares to contact the center leaves
and now you might be wondering well why
should we care about this violent tribe
on this tiny and remote island
well dear viewers that's because it
belongs to the andaman nicobar
archipelago
and while it might not seem like much
this indian territory is
key to international trade
most of the oil tankers that supply
china go through this place this means
that
at any point india could put some
warships here and block
most of china's imports if they did this
china would collapse in a matter of
months and believe me here india
is not china's best friend
so what is china doing to avoid this are
we talking about war
well hopefully not the answer is far
more complex the answer is
once again the string of pearls and in
this video we're going to tell you what
that means
[Music]
in a previous video we discussed how
china is challenging the american empire
the belton road initiative and its
maritime counterpart the string of
pearls are a strategic plan to
neutralize american influence
in the indian ocean we've previously
described the geopolitical theory of the
string of pearls with
each pearl being a port that could host
a military base
[Music]
we said america was worried about this
but they aren't the only ones
india has several reasons to fear
china's military expansion too
but first let's define where these
would-be military bases could be
some of the pearls could be in
bangladesh or sri lanka or pakistan
but hold on a minute because i know what
you're thinking right now all of these
projects they've got
nothing to do with the military so far
we're talking about ports or
airports or highways and those are good
for the economy
right
i mean they really could just be good
investments for chinese companies i mean
who can blame anyone for trying to make
money well let's take sri lanka as an
example we're talking about a poor
country that just emerged
from a civil war
this hambantota port is completely
underdeveloped
and virtually nobody docks there in 2017
only 183 ships arrived here throughout
the entire year
which means most days it was completely
empty
and yet china has invested a billion
dollars here
and if rebuilding a port wasn't enough
they've also created a brand new city
from scratch
right next to it
so now we might want to ask you does
that make any financial sense
whatsoever because it sure doesn't do us
but what if there were other reasons
aside from economics what if china isn't
worrying so much about their roi
and is more worrying about their
military expansion think about it china
is in a very weak position eventually
other countries could block their trade
route and both india and japan might
want to do that at some point
so far the only country that guarantees
safe trade in the indian ocean
is america but america is not exactly
100 committed to china's interest
so in other words china is at an
existential risk and they need their own
security
and that means military bases
now the question is why would other
countries let china build military bases
on their soil and even more importantly
why would those military bases be enough
to guarantee china's security
for example why would having a harbor in
sri lanka keep india from
blocking china's trade routes well today
we're going to answer those questions
but before we do as we always do
let's take a look back at the history
sugar daddy diplomacy sri lanka is that
island that you see
to the south of india it has around 21
million inhabitants and
little to no interest in international
politics
until now
for 26 years sri lanka suffered through
a civil war between the government and a
socialist group the liberation tigers of
tamil
elam this was a conflict where some 60
000 people lost their lives and some
estimations claim that that number could
exceed a hundred thousand
there were human rights violations on
both sides and because of this the
international community isolated sri
lanka's government for decades
that means they could hardly get weapons
and security assistance from the
international market to
fight the tamil tigers and then while
the whole world had turned its back on
sri lanka
a single country stepped up to be their
friend
[Music]
trying this aid revealed in sri lanka's
victory parade
this news is from 2009. back then the
president of sri lanka was
this man here mahindaraj paksa corrupt
authoritarian ruler with
a never-ending hunger for power
he came to power in 2005 and china
offered him all of the military aid he
needed
in order to defeat the tigers thanks to
this in 2009 rash paksa declared victory
over them finally the civil war was over
and
rash paksa got all the credit for it but
this
as you might expect is not the end of
the story you see there's nothing easier
than playing with the egotistical dreams
of a power hungry man
and this is how chyna became rajpax's
[Music]
for example you want to build the
tallest tower in south asia
something as magnificent as it is
useless so
everybody can admire how powerful you
are don't worry rash paxa here's some
money to build it with
would you like to have a modern theater
with your name on it so everyone can be
reminded of you for centuries don't
worry raj rajpaksa
here's some money for that would you
like a deep port in hambantota so you
can
turn your country into the next
singapore don't worry rajpaksa
we've got some money for that too and as
a side note here i've been to sri lanka
and i've seen these white elephants
they're kind of everywhere all of them
they're bought and paid for
with china's money and under china's
conditions and we're not really talking
about small sums of money here
[Music]
sri lanka's debt crisis is so bad the
government doesn't even know how much
money it owes
for a better understanding of just how
much debt we're dealing with
sri lanka's government collected 14.8
billion dollars in taxes last year
nonetheless their scheduled debt
repayments amount to 12.3
billion dollars so basically all of
their income goes towards
debt repayments mainly to china and
still
they continue tow even more money so
what happens when you owe money to china
and china knows that you can't really
pay them back
well that's when that sugar daddy
diplomacy comes in
now yes it's true a sugar daddy can
offer you a life of luxury but it comes
at a price
sometimes it doesn't have to be money in
fact there are many ways of paying a
sugar daddy
back
[Music]
sri lanka formally hands over hambun
tota port to chinese firms
on a 99 year lease of course on this
99-year lease contract it is written
clearly not for military purposes but
good luck telling china what to do with
their own property and look sri lanka is
in so much debt that they can't really
argue with their sugar daddy so now you
might be wondering well what's going to
happen when rajpaksa
is gone well we actually already have
the answer that question
despite his attempt to establish a cult
of personality reshpaksa
lost the elections in 2015. and the new
government they've got a very anti-china
rhetoric but again
money is money and no matter the
ideology of the government
sri lanka is still in a debt trap all
right but i know what you're probably
thinking right now you're thinking
sri lanka's a small country but you know
what about the bigger countries
well let's head over to pakistan
the port of gudar is just another
example of sugar daddying
of a local government have you ever
heard of gudar in pakistan
i certainly had it i had to look up the
name of my computer to how to pronounce
that one
but this area it has become an important
gateway to the 62 billion
china pakistan economic corridor or the
cpec
the first stage of the construction
report took approximately 200
million of investment
[Music]
the china-pakistan economic corridor is
an important loop in the larger chain
of belton road initiative it would
enable the possibility of a 21st century
maritime
silk route he lifeng chairman of
the national development and reform
commission of china
aside from the 62 billion dollars a 2
billion oil refinery
is planned to be set up near gwadar and
you might wonder well does this make
economic sense
well in this case we have to admit that
it does the port of gwadar was built in
a city on the shores of the northern
indian ocean close to the iranian border
and the entrance to the persian gulf a
pipeline from there to the world would
allow them to easily transfer energy
and goods from the middle east it would
also help with trade between
africa the middle east and china in fact
gudar is expected to become a big
commercial hub and of course well it
makes sense for china to control that
but again over 2 billion is enough to
make pakistan's government pretty happy
and increasingly dependent on china if
you want to keep your life of luxurious
infrastructure you've got to keep your
sugar daddy happy and in case you didn't
know we're not talking about a small
country anymore pakistan
has more than 200 million inhabitants
and by the way
it's a die-hard enemy of india
[Music]
and as we're talking about big countries
let's move on to bangladesh
with 164 million inhabitants packed into
570 square kilometers it is one of the
top 10
most densely populated countries on the
planet
[Music]
and guess who sold them most of the
weaponry they use why
china of course all those tanks
anti-missile shields and combat jets
are manufactured in chinese factories oh
they also paid for a gigantic bridge
and of course that non-military port am
i right
estimates say that bangladesh owes 8
billion to china and their army
they're completely dependent on the
chinese again this is sugar daddy
diplomacy
at play so hold on a second because
maybe this doesn't mean
anything to you yet but have a look at
this map
[Music]
what do pakistan sri lanka and
bangladesh have in common
they all perfectly surround india so
well why does this worry
india so much well let's find out
[Music]
the enemy at the gates as we said india
is pretty much surrounded by china's
ports
of course so far these ports have no
military purposes whatsoever but they
might at some point
for example in 2017 china wanted to dock
one of their submarines at the sri lanka
port
the government which was no longer rash
taxes denied permission to china
and since the contract clearly stated no
military use whatsoever
china had to dock their submarine
somewhere else but we all know that
eventually that's probably going to
change some more debt repayment
negotiation and
china's going to be able to ask for
whatever they want
so well what would this mean for india
well do you remember those andamar and
nicobar islands that we talked about at
the beginning of this video well as we
said
india could easily block those roots the
way it is now
china couldn't really do much to avoid
that but imagine
what would happen with chinese military
bases surrounding india
all of a sudden china would be able to
send troops to india's mainland
on all sides this explains why narendra
modi india's prime minister
is so scared about china's expansion and
is playing a double strategy
on the one hand diplomacy
[Music]
indian prime minister narendra modi to
visit china for one-on-one summit with
xi jinping but on the other hand they've
got what we could call the
karaoke strategy basically if china is
building a string of pearls
india wants to do the same but hold on a
second because china has money to sugar
daddy with but
india i mean they're growing a lot
lately but they're not exactly
china so without so much money they're
kind of relying on another powerful
weapon
and that's fear
[Music]
think about it a lot of countries are
concerned about china's military
expansion and that's where india
basically goes and says
hey guys we should probably do something
about this one example is with france in
2018 new delhi's government signed a
strategic pact with france opening up
their naval bases to each other's
warships across the indian ocean
this means that the indian navy now has
access to strategic ports like the one
in djibouti
home to china's only overseas military
base
[Music]
india is scrambling to secure alliances
as china extends its naval dominance in
the indian ocean
india's traditional area of influence
but modi doesn't stop there new delhi's
government is not staying still while
china tries to seduce other countries in
the indian ocean
he finalized an agreement for a new base
in the seychelles and
also negotiated access to naval
facilities in oman
so what does signing all these treaties
and agreements mean for india
it means that they now have access to
their own string of pearls from
madagascar via djibouti oman and the
seychelles
all the way to singapore but hold on a
second because india is not the only
country in the region that doesn't
appreciate china's expansion
last summer taiwan's president chain
wang said that china is a threat to
global democracy and so the taiwanese
government is partnering with europe as
well as japan and the us
in order to bolster its defense against
china while in the past decade china has
promoted itself as the leading source of
infrastructure funding in southeast asia
now india is directly positioning itself
as china's competitor but one country
isn't enough
india needs an ally to contain beijing's
maritime expansion
india is looking at japan as that
possible ally
second meeting of japan india act east
forum
so do you see what we see china is
trying to surround india and now
india is trying to surround china
in geopolitics we have a name to
describe this and it's called a mexican
standoff a mexican standoff is a
situation in which two
or more countries competing over
something can't really win
and so are basically just waiting for
the other to make a false move or
for someone from the outside to step in
so now we've got to ask the question
what's the potential outcome of all of
this well that would be
military escalation basically unless
they come up with a compromise they both
need to keep expanding their military
in order to deter a would-be attack
[Music]
but now you might be wondering what can
america or europe do something about
this
well that's what i'm going to talk about
in the next video in this series where
we discuss another side of the string of
pearls
and that's technology if you don't want
to miss that video subscribe to
visualpolitik and hit that bell button
so you won't miss out on any posts in
the meantime
now it's your turn will china and india
live in a permanent standoff i mean
how long can this situation continue
well leave your comments in the
comments section below and of course
don't forget to visit our friends from
reconsidermedia.com they're the podcasts
that provided the voices
in this video that were not mine and if
you like this video give us a thumbs up
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear more of my lovely voice don't
forget to check out the reconsider
podcast
at reconsider media.com reconsider is a
podcast that challenges you to
reconsider your views by providing
context but we don't do the thinking for
you